um i have a question that someone put in
the super chat
um it's a little different than the
church topic but
if um if our nation was in wartime do
you they really think men do they think
men would really sign up to protect
their nation and women based on how they
are mistreated demonized and not
appreciated
could you say that again please
if our nation was in wartime do you
think that men would sign up to protect
their nation and women
based on how they are mistreated
demonized and not appreciated today if
we if yeah
today you mean well i think most yeah
most men are overweight too so i think
we're in trouble next war i think men
i think the men of nowadays are the
softest yeah i agree you know a little
more so feminine i don't know what china
and russia must be looking at us like
yeah
they must be laughing like these are the
guys that you got yeah you know what i
mean i don't care they're not scared
they're not in the way the world is not
scared not when guys are dying their
hair
green and putting saying i'm asexual and
i'm non-binary yeah it's like asexuals
don't want to have sex doesn't mean
yeah what guy's saying that
no no some people don't want to have sex
a lot of christian men are selling that
yeah but that's not because they don't
want to it's because they understand
that in order to the priests
huh like the priest isn't the father's
are they not selling but that's not
someone signing up to go to war
he's saying like what's what's he saying
he's saying men are treated as
disposable like women are not good to
men in this society and one out of three
men haven't had sex in the past year
and historically men became for women so
they would become something because they
were motivated to provide for their
family
yeah but now they have no woman to
provide for so they're addicted to corn
and video games because they they're
hopeless because nowadays the average
woman doesn't look at the average man
because the dating market is so inflated
because of birth control that we're
sleeping with a smaller and smaller and
smaller percentage of guys you want a
guy that's over six foot fifteen percent
of guys you want a guy that's in the top
half of attraction cut it in half you
want a guy that's in the top half of
income cut that in half
and so
dating app data shows that we swipe
between five to twenty percent of the
time up they get eighty percent of the
matches and so it's like these guys have
no purpose
so what why are they gonna fight for our
country i would say for society to
survive men have to have a purpose
if men feel like in the society they
don't have a purpose i think you are
going to see the decline of
the west see the women have to make you
make that purpose for men that do we
have to make you have but
but that's what we needed for you guys
have a purpose but the to some degree
yeah yeah but i also i also believe that
men are distracted more nowadays there's
more distractions literally they've got
grown-ass men playing computer games
every single [ __ ] day sorry in my
language but it's just like
really like is this your purpose like
you're going to just play games all day
like where's the purpose all day well
and then and
and the problem is that
women like the average woman doesn't get
with the average guy because she's
sleeping with the top guy that's never
going to wife her
and so
and and
and typically before we had to
prioritize other things outside of looks
like we had to otherwise we'd get
pregnant by by the chad right and he's
going to leave because you know he gets
all the women he's not going to provide
so we had to prioritize a provider but
with birth control it allows us to sleep
with the smaller and smaller percentage
of men
and not prioritize the other side of it
and then you know we roll up at 30 35
you know running out of time to have
kids saying take me now
and it's like the average guy
yeah like because and we deny them in
our 20 this is what men are complaining
about average guy
the average guy was that dude at school
that you were at school with that you
know that i know the average guy but i'm
saying the average guy now 45 45 45 k
average looking yeah yeah so what i'm
saying is every child so whenever so
when the girl's been ran through popping
her pills and she goes back to the
average guy is the average guy taking
her
a lot of time a lot of the time yeah
what's the problem because they've got
no other options what's the issue what
are we going to get okay
okay because the issue the issue is that
it only benefits women and so there's a
large there's a large there's a there's
a large portion of men that are very
frustrated because they think that the
woman wants to marry them they think the
woman is excited to be with them when
really she misses her her ex from like
three x's ago they get married she gets
the kids she wants then she starts being
a thought again like sierra right
or or she stops having sex with him
again you didn't see i mean as a mother
and a wife you're gonna be twerking on
top of a car
her husband is happy with him he's
working
but but the point is see it's this is
funny it's like women always excuse
women it's bad behavior you can't come
out
just just you're in the church you
really think that's acceptable i
personally don't think that that's why
okay so then don't excuse it no that's
excuse me okay her husband knew where
she came from but i'm thinking i'm
saying
see that's true
i'm saying that he's a christian man he
went for sierra
yeah we're talking about her behavior
it's always a butt and then the men
allow it this is the same argument she's
been the same from the does she have a
chance yeah she
claimed
she claimed
uh russell wilson and then you can kind
of see her sliding back to actually wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait
wait wait wait wait wait yeah she claimed she
claimed to have changed when she was
about to get married so she waited till
she was married to have sex yeah i used
sierra as an example because it's a
perfect example of what happens all the
time
in a celebrity she dates the future she
dates the bad boys then she's thinking
hmm i need to get married soon i'm
running out of time let me say i've
gotten right with god same thing with
megan good i've gotten right with god
so i can get a husband the husband
thinks she's changed when really she
feels like she's settling for him
and she really wants the guy from the
past and you can see this because she
doesn't respect him enough to not twerk
on a car
like she doesn't like whereas the other
guy like the other would have been like
what the [ __ ] are you doing yeah and
it's it's on the guys too because they
allow it like i'm with you
but they're never allowed out yeah but
the point is that she's
disrespecting him because she doesn't
think that that's the best she could
have done she doesn't view him as
like meaning women don't respect guys
like that
they'll say it but in their actions
you'll see whether or not they respect
guys like that see there's always okay
there are certain women that when they
get with a guy you know that she
respects him and she would never do half
of the things that she would do even
with the other guy that you've seen her
with because she doesn't respect that
guy she's afraid to lose him right and
that's that's how you can tell because
like she's doing all this wild [ __ ]
she's not afraid to lose him no
just like some guys some guys some guys
don't cheat because they're afraid to
lose the girl but i think all those
standards from like since we're talking
about sarah i think all those standards
was more from russell like he was the
one that wanted to wait till marriage
and she just went on to his page because
she liked him yeah so he thought she was
getting on his program and she was it
was just an act so what are they getting
divorced there what's happening no
they're not getting divorced yeah russ
russell i don't know she was actually
russell wilson
yeah
it's the same thing with will smith
yeah like she she dates tupac
and continuously talks about him to the
point where her own daughter is writing
a letter to her
like that's i mean is she afraid to lose
will i mean
this if this is happening to celebrities
the top men that women like i would they
will like i think everyone in this room
would date will smith right i wouldn't
i have my mind
okay but you understand what i'm saying
this is happening to top guys what does
that mean for the average guy and so
these guys get married at 30 thinking
that this girl is excited to be with
them but she's not
she just wants kids she wants kids in a
bit of a element of safety yeah but then
there's some
i mean i mean maybe if for the
for the hose yeah but then
i don't i don't think a lot of girls are
out here hurrying around and being run
through i think most girls unless
they're lying but i think most girls are
you know trying to keep the body count
down and find that man so i think if you
if you're not a hoe and you marry
someone
i don't i don't i think it depends if
you're already like okay whatever then
if that was the case then you'd find
more uh women okay so i i pulled i
pulled i pulled my audience and i said
what do you think the average body count
is for a 20 year old woman in 2022
yeah the the highest answer was 10 to 20
for a 20 year old woman 20 years of age
yeah and uh in the uk oh i
people are from all over the u.s
no they're the audience is mixed
what's the average body count of a 25
year old woman um
45 said over 20.
and then i said what do you think the
average body count is a third of the
average body count of a 30 year old
woman is in 2022. 34 said 30 plus
so if women are keeping it low i i think
the men would
would agree
but they're not like like how would you
so
i would say low is less than five
because when you when you look at when
you look at bonding statistics like like
that's when it switches for women so the
women answer that or men answer the poll
or anyone anyone answered yeah both men
and women oh okay so if we said one yeah
it's it's both it's both and so
like i would say under five would be low
based on data because like women lose
their you start to see repercussions for
sleeping around after five partners
because the average like the average
if a woman gets married and she's only
had sex with one person that she has an
80 chance of a happy marriage if she
slept with more than five it goes down
to 25 so that's when you start to see
the repercussions so like women aren't
keeping their body counts low
and plus this is one of the reasons why
we know why women lie about their body
count
a man a man will promote his body count
a woman will lie about her
but can i ask is there anything
different like between say a woman today
and a woman let's say in the 50s like
psychologically like is there any loads
yeah
of shame kill societal expectations the
risk of pregnancy no so what i'm sorry
let me explain that if you brought a
1950s woman into today's society
would she not behave the same way as the
women behave today she would like women
in the 1950s had cookbooks they were
taught they needed men and they worked
to get a man where women today just
exist they're told not to cook
i don't cook i don't clean that that's
like like our our grandparents worked
through how many women like our
grandparents worked through cheating
like there are so many stories they they
were in it through thick and thin where
women modern women first sign of
cheating they leave it could be one time
thing he could bring it to you she's
leaving she's out and she's taken half
right 1950s he could have a whole side
check across town she's working it out
with her husband it was just a different
i'm not sure
it was it was women had consequences
back then so they acted accordingly
nowadays we took away all the
consequences from women so they act
accordingly but this is the thing like
you keep saying we
whereas
i i give men like the commendation when
i know it's men who have done this like
it's men who
basically built our nation who fought
for us
it is men if we are going to be honest
it is men who are in power and so at the
same time very small percentage of money
that's not necessarily true women make
70 to 80 percent of consumer buying
decisions so you can't necessarily say
that we're not in power a very small
right i mean like make the laws like in
government
right but women vote and women and women
are
like they win elections there's more
women than men
and if they're
and if you're saying men are the ones in
power it's a very small percentage of
men that you're talking about you're
talking about like one percent
of the world's population saying oh men
are in power it's like there's one
percent of like the population that are
in power and they they happen to be men
but it doesn't mean
men in general are like that are in
power no no i'm not saying that i'm just
saying those specific elite men are the
ones who are actually setting
society but the way you guys have
explained it they're setting it based on
what um can keep them in power which is
basically women is how you guys have you
experienced it yes
because i mean how did they get into
power they sold a lot of [ __ ]
like so i'm thinking of like jeff bezos
mark zuckerberg they had to
they had to get used women to get there
basically i want to say you sell what's
this statistic for consumer debt at what
percentage of a consumer debt do women
um they own two i think it's two thirds
of consumer debt
so even though we make less money we
spend more
baby shopping and i think this all the
time because there would be girls that i
know make less than me and i'm like how
are you buying all this [ __ ] i'm like
because i can't afford that i don't know
what the hell you're doing
when i was in the relationship pay for
it there was an amazon delivery nearly
every week at the door i was like what
you bought something again
oh but i needed it
i'm gonna read super